oh oh oh
hi i'm will 4k hi i'm kristen wiig and
we are guest correspondents for wired
we will be reviewing and testing
multi-tool gadgets
[Music]
okay you ready to open this
oh here we go look at all this stuff
this is kind of cool it's like a swiss
army knife but a credit card you know
sometimes when you're like how far away
is that from that and you can take the
card out and be like first of all four
centimeters before i knew that this was
the thing i was like how are we gonna
get in this freaking box the wallet
ninja multi-tool is your everyday tool
that easily fits in your wallet it
functions as a screwdriver bottle opener
box opener can opener cell phone stand
eyeglass screwdriver fruit peeler and
more fruit peeler star star31b2 said got
this for my teenage son stalking for
christmas and he loved it and i got a
cool mom out of that one lol
my husband wants one now
lol
five stars
janelle
said
useless i deeply regret this purchase
one star
all right
so as you can see you can open a box
wait can i see this for a second yeah
check it out oh there's a little
screwdriver thing in here that's kind of
how about this one for you all right let
me find the fruit peeler well this one
oh bottle opener okay you've got this i
believe in you you got this you've got
this right there right this is a bottle
oh this is a bottle
i mean i knew it was a bottle i know the
difference do you though
yes
this is what i would call a can how do
you do that oh oh i see i see you like
this
yeah i don't know how you would uh can
opener screwdriver okay here we go oh
this is amazing look at that that's
great yeah i give this little point uh
an a plus
cell phone stand oh yeah then you do
this with a credit card maybe
what i've just finished lunch and now
i'd like to pay the bill my card is
presented to you
that's great it's
yeah
[Music]
i think it's a great idea it was tough
to open that can but so many useful
things and such a tiny little item
14.98 that sounds that's reasonable
right to me yeah i'm gonna give it to
three stars i agree
this is the atomic bear
paracord bracelet okay
do you put it on your actual body i mean
it's a bracelet oh there's a compass be
ready to survive with the atomic bear
paracord bracelet hey here's an
uplifting quote did you know that cold
is the number one cause of death take
the five survival gear essentials in
just one stylish accessory fire starter
reliable compass loud emergency whistle
ferro rod striker and 12 feet of
military grade paracord so i got a
compass so i always know which way i'm
going i like that oh my god yours and i
are opposites what look your south is on
the top and my nose south is on the
bottom that's not good
if you were lost in the woods together
we would literally try to meet and then
go in opposite directions this comfort
is
uh paracord is trying to keep us apart
pj says that compass doesn't work in one
store i should have tested it before i
went hiking in the jungles of pamama he
spelled pam panama wrong i'm assuming
it's panama it's palmama if you're going
in the jungles of pamama and you don't
have a correct compass yeah
ryan robinson says great for things
great for things but probably not making
waffles five stars so that's good
oh my god that is very loud i mean
that's a good mine doesn't work
will turn around wherever you are go the
opposite way find me
for a rod striker i think i still don't
know what a broad striker is
and then is that it or or is there
something you strike it on here oh the
other end this end
if you need this to survive i'm sorry i
got to give this a two star just based
on the compass thing it's like that's a
big part of it and like we have two
different let's let's make sure what
what is it saying now
south north i'm sorry i might have to
give it a one and a half
okay this is a transforming robot led
flashlight
it's portable energy efficient and
durable a great present for any occasion
amazon customers said made from cheap
plastic that's the good review that's
amazon customer three stars joanna said
not worth your money these are one star
all right so
it's a great light it's a very
lightweight flashlight i'll give it yeah
wait what are these little legs
it kind of looks like an orange
cockroach from the future but are we
missing something did something just
vibrate wait does this come out
oh wait a second oh is that oh oh
it's worth it i could see like if you're
using a little yeah okay
well it says what it is it's a robot
led flashlight so that's what you're
getting you're getting a practical tool
and and i just had a baby and i could
see her in a couple years wanting to
play around with this thing as a toy and
as a useful light i'd give this three
stars
to uh
no you know what i'm not going to have
you shame me i'm not streaming you
number of stars what how many stars do
you give it i
i guess two
the swiss army multi-tool card this is
nine tools in one compact agile and
ready to face any adventure head on the
swiss card showcases innovation
dependability and a unique convenience
style first impression is it talks a big
game it says bunch of uses and we will
be the judge of that i like this
first look because it's kind of like
swiss army but it's flat no name said
clearly a menacing and dangerous array
of deadly armament
five stars
then the king said bad quality i don't
like anything about it one star
let's see what we got here
scissors and a little scissor
yeah okay toothpick
not what is this screwdriver oh a
screwdriver oh do you want to pull
another one out are you sure
now file and we got
there are the tweezers
don't do it don't do it oh i got one
i got one out of your nose yep didn't
that hurt i am so used to
pulling hairs out of my nose okay looks
like there's something right in there
there it is but you can't get it out you
need a tool to get the oh wait i think
you go like this
oh wait wait do you know how to pick a
lock no
no i mean i just shoved stuff up so i
don't know i would be the worst
really i want to learn how to pick a
lock that'd be like a really cool skill
it's quite a lot of handy things and i
get this four i think four stars seems
about right well you know i give it
three stars because it's a little
expensive for for what it is a
billionaire would probably give it uh
four stars are you a billionaire
kristin has to go so
i'm go i have to go north my compass
says to go over there so i'm going to go
that way yes
thanks for having me
i will be handling the final product
i don't even want to read what it is
because i want to see if i can even
figure this out this one like this
but then what would it be used for okay
i'm going to read the thing these are
led flashlight gloves the gloves that
are a flashlight just strap on your led
flashlight gloves and it's as simple as
point and voila so jason said
does the trick i got these especially
with the daylight getting shorter and
walking my dog at night and picking up
his doo-doo the gloves are easy to put
on and off so jason gives it five stars
elle kobach said
quality
it's junk no port for usb no screwdriver
included like box says so many loose
threads not good quality returning all
four and this is one star from elko back
how do we get this light on probably oh
as simple as oh that's interesting look
at that it's not super dark in here so i
just can't tell
it does make me feel a little bit like
spider-man i mean if
oh there we go
and i could do like you know laser light
show
i would take these to a rave but i'm not
really a raver so i would give this to a
friend who's a raver and tell them have
at it tell me how the rave was this
actually does feel like something
magruber would use it's almost a little
fashion statement too it's kind of an
attempt to be real cool and i feel like
mcgruber would think this was a cool
thing i don't know that i'm putting it
on correctly
i think it should cost 9.99 but i bet
it's gonna cost 29.99 ah okay so
somewhere in the somewhere in the middle
i do have two dogs so i think anything
that keeps a poop in the bag is good by
me i'm gonna give it three stars there
were some interesting products the very
first one seems like maybe the one that
i would be most likely to have purchased
it didn't seem like it was too expensive
and it seemed like there were a bunch of
uses and even though the can opener
seemed tough to figure out and it's just
a very helpful tool the things with the
lights you know probably less likely to
buy those and the swiss army thing was a
little expensive but seems like it would
be useful also even the worst we're
still worth uh checking out i'm will
forte wired correspondent
signing off